- Everybody in here right now
in a second,
can think of something
that they're not good at,
that isn't noble, that
they're a bad person in.
In a second that they know
they haven't addressed yet
with themselves.
That's intriguing.
That's the beginning of the process.
(booming music)
(gentle music)
One thing I think I do well
is I make everybody feel safe.
And so that's really
important to me
because when you
make people feel safe,
they start telling you the truth.
I really, really,
really believe the thing
that's holding people back,
is the romantic version of who
they think they want to be,
or who they think they are,
versus who they actually are.
Just 'cause it's cool to
be a start up founder now,
doesn't mean that's
what you need to become.
Mark put on a hoody and
a movie came out and,
you know Instagram
made a billion dollars
after 500 days,
and everybody decided
they were an entrepreneur.
I fully, fully one hundred
thousand per cent with no hedge,
do not believe that you
can teach entrepreneurship.
I'm a humongous believer
that ideas are shit,
and that execution's
the game, right?
We've all got ideas.
Everybody's got ideas.
Do you know how many fucking
ideas we all have here?
We could probably sit here
for the next two hours,
draw them all out, record 'em,
and predict the next
78 great start ups
over the next nine years.
And?
You also have to think about,
what are you good at?
I built a very unsexy business
in the height of where
I was and the game.
Because I was self-aware
that that was going to
be an engine for me
over 10, 20, 30 years.
When it could have been
a lot sexier to raise
50 million dollars and play
with the 14 ideas I have.
But I know who I am.
You can't just say it.
You know how many people
in here that I know intimately
say they're hustlers,
and that I watch 'cause I'm
curious and they're just not.
So you can't just say
you want to go up there,
because if you're
gonna go there,
you're gonna have to look
a lot of shit in the face
that you're not gonna like.
If you do not
have self-awareness,
which is what I do think I have
and I think a lot of
people don't have it,
the only way you can
gain it is by getting
other people to give
you the data points.
But most people
won't tell you the truth.
So it's on you to
create an environment,
a very safe environment,
for somebody to tell you the truth.
This is the most important
question I will ever ask you
in my life.
You need to tell me the truth.
My intuition is, you're not
gonna want to tell me the truth.
But you have to understand
that I'm okay with it.
I'm in the right
mind space for this,
I need the truth.
And then you ask them,
what do they think you're
good at and bad at.
Of what they truly think
you're good and bad at,
and then gather that data.
A lot of people don't want to
recognize what they're good at.
Or don't want to accept that
they're bad at something.
And so, I don't think people
are honest with themselves.
There's a lot of things I wish I was.
But, but I just don't lie to myself.
And I think lying to
yourself has held back the
far majority of this
room from bigger upside.
(booming music)